real guys somebody else who's kind of a
white guy speaking about Street [__]
that's doing well right now is OT shout
out to OT the real
um I know you guys have uh have worked
together what's uh
would you guys ever do a joint project
together or would that be a little too
expected
um no I would do a joint project with
him definitely when the time is right
because he's hard bro yeah he's one of
them MC's like when you're a high level
rapper
it's a difference from doing songs with
you know certain people certain people
you really gotta lock in like you can't
[__] with them there's certain
rappers I could get in the studio I
don't really gotta give you the craziest
[__] cause I'm gonna still be top tier
up here without trying [__] with
somebody who's like this you gotta
really like lock in and pay attention
like if you listen to our back and forth
song everybody should go listen to that
that's I forget what it's called but go
listen to it and um you know that's like
verbal sparring that's just fire would
you and Dave doing a sequel to yours
yeah yeah we're working on that you're
working on it yeah we're working on that
nice he just sent me the first record
for real I like it man who else from
your area or Boston just I guess kind of
just that whole area would you uh say is
on the come up that you're [__] with
that we can shut some light on
um I'm gonna say that there's a there's
a there's a lot of people but I'm gonna
say G Nipsey for sure
um he's in here right now he's going
crazy
um he really had my city like my city
was already
feeling him and involved and there's a
lot of kids from my city that kind of
like get mad at that like why you don't
support me too but I'm like you got to
get the city first get the city you know
so um yeah g Nipsey going crazy died of
the deal of my man
um jigs
and then uh man there's a lot of rappers
out of the trenches in Boston that are
going crazy obviously the the bigger
ones too like beer and you know Joyner
he is like a OG too people don't people
think she just popped off I'm like B has
been now we yeah that's what I'm saying
we if you look at Massachusetts the
rappers we all had the longest roads
yeah be it had a long road man the label
them
Joiner had a long I had a long road B I
had a long road because if you're from
Massachusetts you got to work three
times as hard because it's never been
done